all right go all right here we go off
first pick dearness johnson
cleveland browns the guy that none of us
had heard of comes in and has nearly 100
rushing yards
after nick chubb gets injured and the
broader surprise
300 plus rushing yards even though chubb
only contributed 43.
this browns running game is for real and
it actually hurts nick chubb's
bargaining position when he tries to get
a new contract after the season because
the browns can just look and say we can
do it anyone
yeah no i mean first off i mean he
looked like
legit good like it wasn't just like oh
wow yeah this is a third string running
back oh good
it's kind of he's making do blah blah
blah
i mean that that that was like oh wow
whoa who is that guy i mean that's kind
of what he did to me the first time he
touched
touch the ball um so he's got a chance
to be something and good for them again
if you're going to be a running football
team you better have more than one
running back and good
orchestration of the roster there by the
browns i i think the sunday surprise for
but first of all i'm gonna is that we
haven't talked about this game the
giants defense
all right or do i say lack of rams
offense which one's better i don't know
but i just know i'm all right so lack of
ram's offense
uh and again i think what's a little
and i you know we've hit on this a
little but what's scary about the rams
and and i i
see it is just if they can't run the
ball they a little like your minnesota
vikings that way where it just you know
you can't
they're they're not gonna like put up
points and dominate a game if it becomes
oh we have to drop back the pass to beat
you
and do it that way i just don't think
they i don't know just
it's gonna be interesting to see as we
go forward the giants have a very big
defensive front
and the way that game looked like me
yesterday was they basically went
hey big defensive front you stop the run
and we'll we're going to use some of our
extra guys to take away the boots and
the stuff that mcveigh does to get easy
completions all the time
and because they were able to stop the
run that allowed them to be all over the
boots and the play-action pass and man
the rams uh
did not look good yesterday you're just
upset because the rams covering was one
of your best bets piss me off but no i
don't care but yeah i mean
it was not a good week for picks all
together i don't know how you did but i
know i didn't do very well
straight up against the spread or
anything well since we were
identical i identically straight up it
wasn't good for me either but i want to
know best bets you're uh
one and two i still have two props
tonight the packers and the over in the
late game all right
my next one joe mixon he a double
surprise
he went to the hospital on saturday to
get x-rays because of a chest injury
that showed up on the injury reports
saturday i'm thinking the guy may not
even play
hit 181 yards from scrimmage and three
touchdowns he'd had zero touchdowns all
season
the guy was incredible may end up being
the afc offensive player of the week
for week four and uh coming after we got
the surprise
that he may not play because of the
chest injury incredible performance from
joe mixon i i just hope people can start
to look at this guy
he is one of the five best running backs
in the nfl
he really one of the 15 best five
running backs i know my five now i know
my five i'm down to it i told you from
the start and mixon's in
in it and nick chubb is in it and derek
henry's in it and christian mccaffrey's
in it
and alvin kamara is in it that's where
i'm stopping those are the five best
running backs in football i know there's
some really good
ones out there that i'm leaving off but
you want to put that on social media or
anybody i'll put it on there later
that's my top five running backs
but i'm with you all right he's a beast
that way um
i mean i mean i'm gonna go with
it's a crap surprise but it was a
surprise and you know a big crap
surprise can be just as surprising as a
nice fun
birthday cake surprise all right and
that nick mullins crap surprise last
night is the one that i'm going with all
right
just crap down his leg and everything
i mean holy cow that was horrible so
yeah big crap surprise
on sunday night football right there i
would have never expected that
i mean nick mullins the way he looked
last week and you went oh man i mean
and and 49er fans i'm going out there in
the regional sports network
they're on me all the time because i
made jimmy garoppolo my 19th rated
quarterback they think he should be
higher
and then last week i'm on there and they
want to go should we bench him for nick
mullins i mean
that just tells you the world we're in
but regardless uh
mullins that was just everything was bad
last night throwing pocket presents
taking care of the ball crap surprise
nick mullins
i've got a different surprise than what
we usually do but i think it's important
it needs to be mentioned
john gruden big surprise seriously
that he is tempting fate with a
potential suspension
or loss of draft picks when the nfl has
already hit him
for a hundred grand and the team for 250
and the team for another 50 for having
an unauthorized person in the locker
room
and the ridiculousness we saw last
monday from all those raiders players
that were at an event in an enclosed
space
with no masks in sight for gruden to
have
and he he got rid of the loincloth he
went back to the traditional like neck
gator
but for him to have that thing as a
jowls catcher
on sunday instead of up over his face
what's he expect the league to do
he's sticking his finger in their eye
over and over again and i know it's the
raiders and that's part of the mystique
but dude if you're not coaching next
week there's a reason for it
it's going to be because the nfl is
making you the poster boy
for the example they're going to make of
anyone that gives them the middle finger
over these protocols and the calls
happening later today
i won't be surprised if at the end of
the day we find out gruden's been
suspended or the paid uh the
raiders have lost a i'm so used to the
patriots losing draft picks the raiders
have lost a fifth round draft pick or a
fourth round draft pick for what's
happened i'm just guessing
not reporting but it won't surprise me
if it happens man i mean there there was
a few coaches we saw i of course i
saw of course gruden yes uh you're right
i mean they're they're playing with fire
there's no doubt about it i mean
especially after everything that's
happened the last time i i just
yeah that's kind of the surprising thing
i mean with the league and everything
that's gone on the country everything
that's gone on
yes i understand it man would they
really have the guts
to suspend a head coach though off of it
that that would be
like big time big time or did they just
find them another big check i don't know
what happens
there but what gets their attention
what's going to get a coach's attention
what's going to get his attention yeah
money take a week off draft picks or a
week off right yeah
week off week off is going to get their
attention all right what else you got
all right
um i i think i'm just going to go i'm
gonna go with teddy bridgewater
and i don't mean it it's more than him
it's the panthers offense but just
everything they did yesterday
and he is the focal point i mean you you
mentioned it earlier
for bridgewater the movement the way
he's played for the most part been
pretty damn
good other than a few mistakes against
the bucks and
uh they're i mean just they're very
efficient they really are
they controlled the ball yesterday they
never let arizona really get in a rhythm
really part of the great reason they
defended arizona so well
is because their offense kept the ball
away from arizona too and he threw
high percentage passes good screens they
run the ball
so to me that was one of the pleasant
surprises of sunday just carolina matt
rule
teddy bridgewater and what they got
going on there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports